invités politiques de la matinale jean
frédéric poisson président de via la
voix du peuple est avec nous ce matin
[Musique]
jean frédéric poisson bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on va
revenir sur la question de la
vaccination obligatoire mais avant on
attend dans la journée la décision du
conseil d'état pour rouvrir les théâtres
musées cinémas on sait vous vous êtes
engagé vous pour la réouverture des
lieux de culte alors est ce que comme
les lieux de culte vous jugé
indispensable nécessaire la réouverture
des lieux de culture cette fois je crois
indispensable l'olympia par tous les
moyens de ce qui fait le sel le goût de
la vie humaine c'est-à-dire d'abord tout
ce qui touche à la vie de l'esprit alors
je ne méconnais pas une faille manger
travailler se déplacer
évidemment mais si je voulais dire les
choses précisément je dirais que l'une
vit dans laquelle on retire tout ce qui
est affectif culturelle spirituelle
sociale
j'étais pas très bien quelle chance
parra et je sais par thales que sa
manière d'être bien portant dans un
monde où chacun vit chez elle persuada
de relation et plus personne n'a accès
aux biens spirituels du culturel c'est
le monde il se profile celui dans
lesquels dans lequel je crois les
français refusent de vivre est ce qui
explique qu'au delà de la protestation
des professionnels de la culture
et comme d'ailleurs les restaurateurs et
d'autres l'ont fait il ya quelques jours
les français eux mêmes commencent à
comprendre que tout ça et qu'on a mis
très très exagérées par rapport à la
réalité du risque sanitaire
c'est la question de la vaccination
obligatoire qui a créé du remous face à
l'indignation massive après la diffusion
du projet doit instituer un régime
pérenne de gestion des crises sanitaires
le ministre de la santé l'a assuré il
n'y aura pas de vaccination obligatoire
cette affirmation d'olivier ferrand à ce
qu'elle vous rassure non il ya très
longtemps je n'ai plus aucune confiance
dans ce gouvernement de biens publics
utiles de notre pays malheureusement ne
sont pas le cas mais je constate que
chaque semaine qui passe que nous avons
des raisons supplémentaires de de
constater qu'on nous ment en permanence
et que la manipulation et 2000 les
propos de me de la santé il est simple à
comprendre
la vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
mais si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous ne pouvez pas accéder aux moyens de
transports publics alors tu attends de
l'établissement recevant du public
et j'ajoute je me permets d'apporter
cette précision à votre reportage à face
entre d'activité nous serons nous serons
rendu impossible légalement on sait pas
très bien lesquels mais autrement dit
c'est pas obligatoire mais si vous
n'êtes pas vacciné vous ne pouvez plus
rien faire vous ne pourrez pas vivre
alors je pense que quand on en arrive à
ce degré de manipulation et de mensonges
ça devient très grave
si vous voulez quand on dirige un pays
alors vous avez réagi 1 sur ce dossier
hier notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez réagi en publiant une vidéo
qui date de 2016
des propos de jacques attali je vous
propose de les écouter et puis vous nous
expliquer pourquoi ensuite tout
gouvernement qui sortirait de l'état
d'urgence donnerait le sentiment d'une
faiblesse c'est malheureusement aussi
absurde que le principe de précaution
qui lui même est excessif mais dont plus
personne ne peut sortir
on crée parfois d irréversibilité nous
sommes en état d'urgence mais par nature
nous devons être en permanence dans un
état d'urgence et le fait de le
signifier par des institutions ne fait
qu'exprimer une réalité quoi vous avez
tenu à relayer ces propos hier vous
craignez l'état d'urgence sanitaire soit
irréversible aujourd'hui je prends
d'abord il fois au privatifs de liberté
ou une agression à l'égard de liberté
individuelle comme il y a eu peu
d'agressions cette nature dont histoire
dans l'histoire française récente en
tout cas ce qu'ont tous data vie est
intérêts de jacques attali est
intéressant parce que il n'y à un autre
endroit de la vidéo que j'ai publié que
si les bacs on n'a pas de projet
politique en tout cas lui il en a un et
que emmanuel macron sera la personne
tout à fait parfaite pour porter le
projet politique et donc celui de
jacques attali
c'est ce qui est démontré depuis trois
ans ça m'intéressait de le rappeler sur
les réseaux sociaux
je crois qu'au fond le projet politique
qui est porté par monsieur attali c'est
à dire celui d'un monde ouvert la
fameuse apple ça s'agite il avait été
ouverte de leur chance
c'est le même projet en définitive tout
cela nécessite effectivement ne comporte
changer tout cela nécessite que on
rabote nos libertés ça justifie que
effectivement le on veut supprimer
l'argent liquide et la circulation
d'argent liquide encore une fois on
reste rendre nos propres libertés se
justifie qu'on surveille les opposants
sur des réseaux sociaux pour ça il
cohérent je ne parle pas d'un projet
caché le projet est ouvert il est public
tout le monde les connaît il est
accessible à tous mais je dis simplement
que à l'occasion de cette crise
sanitaire nous voyons que ce projet dans
régime hautement de l'humanité tout
entière pour installer un gouvernement
mondialistes très clairement et
internationaliste au fond est bien à
l'occasion de cette crise sanitaire ce
projet politique progresse et que il a
besoin de notre moindre liberté pour
nous il a besoin de vous contenir nous
tissons s'exclame cet opposant de nous
faire taire de nous empêcher d'aller là
où nous voulons de restreindre la
capacité de déplacement de réunions
publiques demande de publication c'est
des allocations des réseaux sociaux
et donc voilà tout cela est parfaitement
cohérent et ce défi d'un ensemble dont
le projet de loi sur la vaccination
obligatoire car je maintiens qu'avec six
nations en fait sur obligatoire tout
cela tout cela ne fait que reporter si
vous voulez cette impression globalement
français participent à l'instauration de
cette société et internationales contre
laquelle je m'élève depuis longtemps du
coup l'interdiction par le conseil
d'état de l'usaj des drones pour
surveiller les manifestants vous salue
et donc cette décision oui alors il se
trouve qu'ils rêvent comme quelques
îlots de résistance dans ce monde compte
qui devient fou et qui est gouverné par
des gens qui eux même perdre la raison
le conseil d'état estimant qu' il
fallait comme tout de même pas aller
trop loin trop c'est trop d'une certaine
façon et il a rappelé comment dire
utilement que il est contraire à la
protection des libertés publiques
alors que bâle à bienne et à celle de
tous nos auditeurs de surveiller de
manière massive ou exagérées excessive
les citoyens français cet après midi à
15h nous sommes entendus par le conseil
d'état puisque nous avons nous attaquer
trois décrets qui vise au fichage des
opinions six religieuses les syndicats
de tous les français potentiellement et
j'espère que pour les mêmes
conseil d'état sanctionnera ces décrets
pris par me l'intérieur et des ventes en
quelques semaines au motif que c'est
cette mécanique de surveillance
généralisée et disproportionnée n'a pas
de raison d'être même pour combattre les
menaces qu'il faut combattre bien sûr
alors en quelques mots la question
d'identité nationale elle a fait surface
il hier après l'autre les entretiens des
manuels macron paru hier dans l'express
le chef de l'état y avoir mille et une
interrogations qu'est ce que être
français alors sa réponse était être
français c'est d'abord habité une langue
et une histoire c'est à dire s inscrire
dans un destin collectif pour vous jean
frédéric poisson est ce que vous
rejoignez cette définition est président
de la république c'est quoi en quelques
mots pour vous être français aujourd'hui
je pourrais faire bien ses propos du
président du lille je trouve que
l'inscription dans une une tradition ou
suite de génération l'ancrage raynaud
rapidement dont on rend en territoire un
peuple une langue une histoire tout ça
me va très très bien
je regrette que le président la
république n'en tire pas les
conséquences et que lui qui est fiat de
temps en temps en tout cas à définir les
choses de manière à peu près convenable
qui le commet dire qu'il ne récupère pas
s'il veut dire ou qui n'inclut pas dans
son agir dans ce sens pratique le
définition de lui-même je suis surpris
de boire de la facilité avec laquelle je
me souviens la facilité avec laquelle
pendant la campagne présidentielle davet
de dire d'algérie qu'il n'y avait pas de
culture française
je constate son attachement la société
multiculturelle même s'il le nie
dans cet article de l'express enfin tout
son action va contre ses ennemis et le
problème que nous avons avec ce pouvoir
c'est cela c'est que quand il ne ment
pas ce qui lui arrive très souvent quand
il ne ment pas il tient sans cesse de
discours en même temps c'est le cas de
le dire je ne suis pas l'inventeur de la
formule de regarder ce que je dis mais
le fait d'écouter ce que je dis ne
faites pas ce que je fais jacques stern
le couvre-feu le l'embarras temps je le
viol et du coup la trappe virus tout
tout est à la demande comme ça bon vous
feront pour cette interview du président
ça n'est pas la crise d'autorité qui
alimente le complotisme ses mensonges et
le mépris et je regrette que le traînera
république n'oublie que très peu de
choses sur cet aspect de sa propre
manière de gouverner mais
si beaucoup jean frédéric poisson
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je rappelle que
vous êtes président de vela à la voix du
peuple